[Musica]
le azioni ordinarie generano effetti
straordinari siamo soliti pensare che
solo le grandi storie sono le grandi
imprese siano in grado di generare
effetti straordinari nella vita delle
persone
il mio pensiero controverso mi porta
invece a credere che siano le azioni
semplici le azioni di tutti i giorni le
azioni quotidiane le azioni ordinarie a
generare effetti meravigliosi e
inaspettati sulle straordinarie però non
riponiamo mai tanta attenzione perché
possono sembrare banali scontate
succedono tutti i giorni
eppure possono celare l'innesco di una
serie di eventi in grado di determinare
le nostre scelte e la nostra vita
oggi vi raccontano tre storie e per
trovare l'ispirazione ho immaginato di
parlare con mio fratello che oggi è qui
in sala come faccio spesso nella vita e
mi sono reso conto che oggi il mio
pubblico a cui voglio essere più vicino
a cui mi voglio rivolgere più
intensamente sono i ragazzi presenti in
questa sala perché mi sento vicino a voi
e perché vorrei che potesse raggiungere
più velocemente di me le consapevolezze
di cui ora vi parlo la prima storia si
chiama consapevolezza del flusso era
gennaio 2015 volevo andare in erasmus
dovevo scegliere la città
sarei partito un anno dopo il mio quinto
e ultimo anno di giurisprudenza
avevo optato per la spagna è in me era
molto forte al tempo la volontà di
diventare avvocato di proseguire la
carriera forense
pertanto la scelta della città doveva
essere supportata da ragioni di
specializzazione professionale quando
sono mi sono presentato ai colloqui con
le prime due professoresse delle mie due
mete predilette che erano siviglia per
motivi di diritto internazionale e
granada per la parte civilistica ero
carico io ero a caccia di stimoli ero
pieno di entusiasmo
ho incontrato due professoresse che da
subito appena mi sono seduto hanno
iniziato a parlarmi di numeri quanto
esaminato quanti esami mi mancano che
mediò cosa voglio fare dopo in che
materia voglio specializzarmi come
potevo dire loro che nella vita
sostanzialmente avrei voluto realizzare
i miei sogni
sarei voluto stare bene forse avrei
voluto aiutare le persone e ascom un po
scoraggiato da questi due colloqui così
decido di farne un terzo che era un po
fuori dalla dal mio radar dalla mia
orbita con la terza meta quella terza
scelta era alicante senza troppe
aspettative una settimana dopo mi
presentai da questa professoressa chiara
referente per questo amenta che mi
accoglie con un grande sorriso nel suo
studio e mi disse si eviti parlami di te
avrà avuto 10 12 anni in più di me era
giovane era stata anche lei una
studentessa ad alicante e ora non solo
insegnava a bologna ma in alcuni periodi
dell'anno insegnava anche a buenos aires
e in spagna proprio ad alicante mi parla
di tutto mi parla dell'università della
spagna della della sua esperienza mi
parla delle persone che ha conosciuto
della vita notturna persino e io a quel
punto mi sento ascoltato mi sento molto
compreso anche se una vocina dentro di
me mi faceva ancora queste domande ma
perché alicante cosa rappresenta
alicante nel tuo futuro
come ti può aiutare la professoressa
chiarisce i miei dubbi dicendomi sono
state ad alicante come studentessa e ora
si tornò abitualmente ad insegnare puoi
partire per l'erasmus avendo pianificato
al dettaglio tutta la tua vita oppure
vuoi vivere un'esperienza che la vita te
la può cambiare pensaci e poi ci
risentiamo emozionato è ovviamente molto
motivato esco da questo colloquio chiamò
subito i miei genitori per aggiornarli e
mi ricordo che mio babbo mi disse fidati
di quest alicante fidati dell'entusiasmo
di questa professoressa un anno dopo
partita la scena mia con te partì alla
volta di alicante con un bagaglio
pesante di responsabilità esasperate di
stress
po di paura per il domani un po di ansia
per il futuro arrivo ad alicante e
scopro una vita completamente diversa
scopro la leggerezza la spensieratezza
seguire cose che ti entusiasmano
ascoltare le tue passioni ascoltare te
stesso conoscere delle persone che in
poco tempo diventano la tua famiglia e
vado a vivere dei sei mesi che sono
stati talmente intensi che sono durati
praticamente 10 anni per la prima volta
mi resi conto che nella vita avrei
dovuto ottenere un equilibrio tra quello
che ero prima e quello che stavo vivendo
in spagna avrei dovuto trovare il giusto
senso dell'equilibrio e mi resi conto
ancora per la prima volta che le cose
che mi succedevano le persone che
incontravo non facevano parte di un
copione casuale mi senti attraversato
per la prima volta da un flusso
potentissimo di energie di persone di
accadimenti krishnamurti filosofo
indiano del novecento diceva che essere
significa essere in relazione e la
relazione crea continuità questa
continuità la continuità dei nostri
sentimenti
la continuità dei nostri valori la
continuità dell'esperienza questa
continuità questo flusso perpetuo
attraversa tutta la nostra vita e si
manifesta talvolta in maniera più lieve
e talvolta in maniera più importante lo
dobbiamo ascoltare lo dobbiamo seguire
perché è importante ascoltarlo vive
dentro di noi nasce nella nostra
interiorità è qualcosa di spirituale che
però emerge nella vita reale nella vita
concreta perché allo scopo di creare e
fortificare relazioni umane
il flusso ci guida non non si determina
le scelte
tornai da alicante e capi che quello
dovevo fare dovevo seguire le mie
passioni ascoltarmi di più fare
a volte magari delle scelte controverse
che però tendessero all'essenza della
mia felicità della mia soddisfazione
della mia realizzazione e quella
professoressa una volta tornato in
italia fu importante e ben ruolo
ulteriore perché fu mia relatrice per la
tesi è il giorno della mia laura quando
mi abbracciò commossa in quelle lacrime
senti profondamente l'entusiasmo e la
soddisfazione di quei due anni di
percorso e la soddisfazione di aver
aiutato un ragazzo come me a raggiungere
un importante consapevolezza
talvolta è importante lasciarsi guidare
dal flusso cercare delle risposte in
esso perché il flusso crea emozione crea
meraviglia e della meraviglia che
stimola la nostra creatività che apre i
nostri cuori che si ispira e che ci
permette di vedere in maniera più nitida
tutte le opportunità che ci circondano
la seconda storia si chiama
consapevolezza delle nostre emozioni e
il 2016 sono ad alicante tarda primavera
questa piccola digressione è uno spin
off che non conosce neanche mia mamma
però mamma tranquilla perché è una
storia a lieto fine ero afflitto da un
mal di testa atroce da più di dieci
giorni e mi chiedevo perché perché non
passa in quella in quel periodo avevo un
caro amico che era ricoverata in
ospedale e questo mi portava a fargli
compagnia tutte le sere allora
sfruttando la circostanza che rosa in
ospedale è soprattutto coniugata alla
mia malcelata ipocondria decisi di fare
un accertamento più approfondito e fece
una tac cerebrale
l'ospedale di someone con la sua
efficienza mi consegnò in 60 minuti
il risultato di questa visita erano
circa le 23 30 era notte e mi fece a
como non c'era nessuno c'ero solo io e
la mia tac mi fece accomodare un medico
ovviamente spagnolo una donna e mi disse
poi adesso è stato tranquillo tiene solo
un ape kenya vena gordita una vena
gordita letteralmente significa una vena
grassottella io ero lì da solo lontano
dalla mia famiglia e in questa stanza di
ospedale mi viene detto che ho una
piccola anomalia nel cervello tant'è che
iniziò a tempestare il medico di domande
cosa significa è grave non è grave
quanto è grave un po preso dall'ansia
dall'angoscia dal timore e da quella
ipocondria di cui parlavo prima
il medico cerca di tranquillizzarmi mini
se no non ti preoccupare no no no io
sono preoccupato io voglio sapere qual è
la cosa peggiore che mi può capitare e
mi disse beh la cosa peggiore che ti può
capitare è morire vede che sono
particolarmente alterato e allora decide
di tranquillizzarmi più seriamente un po
rasserenato mi congedo dal medico ma
prima di uscire ingordo più della mia
vena del di sapere bene cosa mi stesse
succedendo e cosa significasse
quell'anomalia nel mio cervello mi
chiesi mi dia un consiglio da qui a
quando torno in italia cosa posso fare
per questa vena gordita poi dopo in
italia verificherò farò altre però in
questi due mesi che mi restano di vivere
da vivere in e radu cosa posso fare
la cosa ma suona che poi del sasser e
senza d'arte lo meno possibile into vita
arrabbiati il meno possibile nella tua
vita
il consiglio di quel medico detto quasi
come fosse una battuta mi fece capire
che forse dovevo farlo veramente e da
quel giorno mi esercita e costantemente
e quotidianamente
con poche difficoltà ad arrabbiarmi
sempre meno ea controllare la rabbia
lira chiamiamola come vogliamo
e mi sono reso conto innanzitutto la
cosa bella è che la battuta di un medico
spagnolo aveva generato che
apparentemente era una cosa negativa
stava generando un miglioramento della
mia vita e lo sta generando tuttora
perché l'esercizio continua ovviamente
ma soprattutto mi resi conto e mi chiesi
più che altro se io riesco a essere a
controllare la mia rabbia
significa che sono consapevole di quando
vivo con l'emozione negativa e se sono
consapevole di quando vivo un emozione
negativa allora significa che devo posso
e voglio essere consapevole anche di
quando vivono emozione positiva per
esempio quando sono felice come oggi la
consapevolezza delle nostre emozioni si
aiuta con il giusto allenamento a
gestire le emozioni negative ea vivere
intensamente e pienamente le emozioni
positive
la terza ed ultima storia che vi voglio
raccontare si chiama consapevolezza
della propria missione autunno 2016 sono
sempre nello stesso anno erasmus finito
l'estate è finita ho collezionato
tantissime esperienze ma ho ancora fame
di altro voglio conoscere sono preso da
un entusiasmo romantico che jack kerouac
definiva tremende citazione di vita così
decisi di partire per fare un piccolo
pellegrinaggio sulla via degli dei un
antico collegamento romano attraverso
l'appennino tosco emiliano che collegava
a bologna e firenze e non vado da solo
vado con mario il mio amico mario
conosciuto due mesi prima ad alicante ed
era diventato subito un fratello
partiamo non eravamo allenati
dopo i primi dieci chilometri infatti si
inizia a sentire un po la stanchezza
allo zaino pesa sulle spalle
decidiamo di fermarci per mangiare
qualcosa ma non troviamo non troviamo
nulla non troviamo nulla perché non ci
va bene questo posto perché non ci
piazza e questo non è abbastanza immerso
nel verde
qui non sappiamo dove sedersi andiamo
avanti dobbiamo
ma il posto perfetto per fare il primo
pranzo del nostro pellegrinaggio al che
arriviamo a sasso marconi
passiamo il ponte di vista sul fiume
reno e troviamo uno splendido punto
panoramico in un piccolo paesello
e a quel punto esce dalla porta di una
casa la signora da la signora ada con la
tipica premura di una nonna si viene
incontro offrendoci un panino col
prosciutto e una coca cola
a quel punto ci sediamo mangiamo beviamo
esigiamo che la signora da si racconti
la sua storia la signora da aprile al
suo ristorante il primo giugno del 1952
assieme alla sua famiglia e dopo 63 anni
di lavoro e di ristorazione e dopo
migliaia di tortellini e crescentine
servite ai pellegrini sulla via degli
dèi aveva cessato la sua attività
nonostante questo però la signora ada
era ancora lì tutti i giorni sulla sua
sedia a dondolo ad accogliere i
pellegrini offrendogli non solo una
merenda ma anche consigli e scorciatoie
lungo il viaggio
quale era il segreto della signora da
perché continuava a fare questo perché
la signora da era consapevole della sua
missione
la signora da ci ha spiegato che ama la
vita se l'ha dimostrato ama il suo
lavoro e alla sua veneranda età non è
mai stanca di aiutare le persone
quindi se noi siamo consapevoli della
nostra missione abbiamo la possibilità
innanzitutto di rendere straordinaria
qualsiasi giornata ordinaria e la
consapevolezza della nostra missione ci
permette di fare delle scelte sempre
funzionali ai nostri obiettivi
a dispetto poi di quello che dicono
molti la nostra generazione
la nostra generazione è una generazione
ottimista noi siamo una generazione
positiva siamo una generazione che vuole
costruire che vuole creare economia
lavoro che non ha paura di assumersi
delle responsabilità che non si lamenta
che cerca le soluzioni che vuole pulire
il mondo che è attenta alle tema
tic e sociali che a 20 anni sogna di
aprire una start up che può cambiare il
mondo
questa è la nostra generazione noi siamo
una generazione positiva
siamo una generazione romantica ecco
quello che siamo siamo una generazione
romantica 3 consapevolezze
consapevolezza del flusso consapevolezza
delle proprie emozioni consapevolezza
della propria missione vi ho raccontato
tre storie che sono le storie che ognuno
di voi potrebbe vivere nella propria
vita
ma da dove sono partite queste storie da
cosa sono state originate quali azioni
straordinarie e inenarrabili hanno dato
origine a questi aneddoti il consiglio
di una professoressa
la battuta di un medico spagnolo e un
panino col prosciutto crudo bevuto o
mangiato assieme una coca cola lungo il
sentiero
[Applauso]
[Musica]